-Hey, everyone.
Tonight is our 1,000th show.
In a different time,
you could have expected
an evening filled with
celebrity guests
and looks back at
our funniest moments.
Instead, it's a
one-man extratticganza.
[ Foghorn blows ]
I don't know -- maybe
at the end, to celebrate,
my kids will come out and say,
"This has been 'A Closer Look.'"
I guess you'll just have to
stick around and find out.
Anyway, the extratticganza
must go on.
President Trump's
political standing is as
weak as it's ever been,
so he's decided
to pin his hopes for a comeback
on whining about polls
and sticking up for
the...Confederacy?
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
As his poll numbers
continue to fall
and he descends deeper
into political desperation,
President Trump is as
fixated as ever on things
he sees on TV
that make him feel bad,
like, for example,
a new CNN poll
that puts his
job approval rating at 38%
and has him losing to
Joe Biden by 14 points.
Now, the president's job
approval is tracked constantly,
and especially
in an election year,
new polls come out all the time.
So obsessing over any one poll
is mostly a waste of time,
which is exactly why Trump
is doing it,
because the guy loves
to waste time.
It's the only thing
he's good at.
His favorite sport
takes five hours to play
and makes drying paint
look like a fireworks show.
And when he's not golfing,
he's glued to the TV,
which might explain why
his brain, long ago,
melted into rice pudding.
The human mind just wasn't built
to withstand that much Hannity.
Humans evolved
from hunter-gatherers.
Trump evolved from a
Cro-Magnon who spent the day
staring at a cave painting of an
angrier Cro-Magnon.
Just yesterday, Trump tweeted,
"Incredible!
Fox News just took Congressional
hearing off the air
just prior to important
witness statements.
More like CNN. Fox is lost."
He tweeted that at 10:56 a.m.
on Wednesday.
Why are you watching TV at
11:00 a.m. on a Wednesday?
Did you get furloughed
and not tell anyone?
[ As Trump ] The good news is,
I still have my health insurance
and, you know,
all the money I stole."
[ Normal voice ]
There are mass demonstrations
in the streets
against systemic racism.
police are beating
peaceful protesters,
a pandemic is still raging,
and tens of millions of people
have lost their jobs,
and the president is
live-tweeting cable news
in the middle of a workday
like a high-school sophomore
playing hooky from school.
In fact, even
a high-school sophomore
would know better than to tweet,
"I pretended to be sick today
so I could stay home
and watch 'Price is Right'
@PrincipalSimms."
And now the president,
who's obviously anxious
about his political standing,
apparently has so much free time
on his hands that
he's watching cable news
and getting mad at polls.
-Brand-new CNN poll
hot off the press.
It shows a huge drop in
the president's approval rating
in just one month,
down 7 points.
It also shows former
vice president Joe Biden
opening up his biggest lead yet,
14 points, over President Trump.
-The Trump campaign is
actually demanding that CNN
retract and actually apologize
for our recent poll
that shows the president
is trailing
the presumptive Democratic
presidential nominee,
the former vice president,
Joe Biden.
-Why does that upset you?
You were behind in the polls
to Hillary Clinton,
and now, thanks to our
dumb electoral college,
you're president.
You're not the hare.
You're the tortoise.
And your shell is like
a bunker you retreat to --
not because you're scared,
but because you're doing
an inspection.
This all started when Trump saw
the poll and got so pissed,
he actually asked his pollster
to debunk it, tweeting,
"I have retained
highly respected pollster
McLaughlin & Associates
to analyze today's
CNN poll (and others),
which I felt were fake,
based on the incredible
enthusiasm we're receiving.
Read analysis for yourself.
This is the same thing
they and the others did
when we defeated crooked
Hillary Clinton in 2016.
They are called
suppression polls
and are put out to
dampen enthusiasm."
First of all, it must be
the easiest thing in the world
when Trump retains your services
as a pollster to prove something
is fake, because you could just
give him a one-page print-out
that says he was right.
And then if he
asks if there's any data,
you say, "Yeah, do you
want to see it?",
knowing full well he'll just
say, "No, no, no, no, no, no.
I trust you. I trust you."
I mean, I'd say it
was free money,
but, then again,
he never pays anyone.
So it serves you right
for working for him,
McLaughlin & Associates.
Trump's political standing
has eroded considerably
over the past month,
and he's in a weak position
as any incumbent president
has ever been in the history
of modern polling.
So Trump and his supporters in
the GOP and on right-wing TV
are resorting to the only
two tactics they have left --
amping up the racism and nursing
deranged cultural grievances.
For example,
after the Army -- the Army --
said they were considering
renaming bases
that had been named after
Confederate leaders,
who were violent white
supremacists and traitors,
Trump lashed out on Twitter.
And, for some reason,
his White House handed out
physical copies of his statement
to reporters in the press room.
-The president is dismissing an
idea under consideration
by the Pentagon
of renaming bases
that honor Confederate officers.
-Now, let me just
tell you what happened
in the last few minutes here
to give you a sense of
how this went down at
The White House.
The president, of course, just
tweeted a few moments ago,
and then they handed out
a print-out
of the president's tweet.
The press secretary
came out and also read
the president's tweet,
where he said, in part,
"These monumental
and very powerful bases
have become part of
a great American heritage
and a history of
winning victory and freedom."
He says, "Therefore,
my administration
will not even consider
the renaming
of these magnificent and fabled
military installations."
-"Our history as
the greatest nation in the world
will not be tampered with.
Respect our military."
So, that was directly
from the president.
We spent some time
working on that.
-I'm not sure that's something
I'd necessarily brag about.
It's one paragraph.
From the looks of it,
it's like a 14-size font.
I've seen longer blurbs
on book jackets.
It's like the first draft
of a college essay
that's supposed
to be five pages,
and instead of writing more,
you just jack up the spacing.
Also, what do you mean they're
"part of a great
American heritage and a history
of winning, victory,
and freedom?"
Confederates famously fought
against America, and they lost.
Since when do we name
military bases
after people who lost wars
against Americans?
Is there a naval base named
after King George III?
Would you make American soldiers
trade at Fort Il Duce?
Also, I love this part.
"Magnificent and fabled military
installations."
Those bases are a lot of things,
but they're not fabled.
They're really there.
We're not talking about an
Aztec city of gold.
"Gather around
and I'll tell you the tale
of a fabled Ft. Bragg,
a charmless cluster
of wooden buildings where
men fall from the sky,
wings of nylon."
And, by the way, not only were
Confederate leaders
slavers, traders,
and white supremacists,
they were also dip[bleep]
Take general Braxton Bragg,
for example.
Bragg resigned from the
Confederate Army
after losing a decisive battle.
And on top of that, Bragg was a
jackass and an ass[bleep]
Bragg had such a notoriously
bad temper
that Union
general Ulysses S. Grant,
in his memoirs, recalled a story
of one of Bragg's superiors
admonishing him --
"My God, Mr. Bragg,
you have quarreled with every
officer in the Army,
and now you're quarreling
with yourself."
No wonder Trump likes him.
He was a racist psycho
who liked to fight with people.
They didn't have
Twitter back then,
but I'm guessing
Bragg's telegrams
would have been right up
Trump's alley.
"Dear General Grant,
I have retained
highly respected pollster
McLaughlin & Associates
to analyze the results of
the Civil War,
which I felt were fake,
based on the incredible
enthusiasm we are receiving.
Lyin' Lincoln is a loser!
Regards, General Bragg.
P.S., I spent a good bit of time
working on this."
I listened to a lot of tapes to
get that impression right.
Trump probably likes him
because he thinks
he invented bragging.
"You know, before Braxton Bragg,
you just had to
hope people knew
how rich you were
without you telling them.
It was a dark time.
It was a very dark time."
Also, it's worth noting that all
of these Confederate generals
Trump is praising
probably would have hated him.
I mean, sure,
he's also a racist,
but there's no way they'd
enjoy spending time
with this New York City
blowhard.
If he was at
one of their cotillions,
Trump would have been
glove-slapped
every five minutes.
"For the insult of your
locker-room talk,
I challenge you to
a duel at dawn, good sir."
[ As Trump ] Well,
I can't do dawn tomorrow.
I've already been challenged
to a duel then.
Does next Wednesday work?"
[ Normal voice ] So,
as he plummets in the polls,
Trump thinks his ticket to a
political resurgence
is appealing directly to
racists who idolize
the white-supremacist
Confederacy,
but he's clearly
facing head winds,
because even the
cultural institutions
you might think of
as occupying conservative end
of the spectrum are dumping
the Confederate symbols.
The U.S. Navy
has joined the Marines
in moving to ban the
Confederate battle flag.
And even NASCAR is weighing in
with a firm
anti-Confederacy stance.
-On Wednesday, NASCAR officially
banned the Confederate flag
from all events after a request
from Bubba Wallace,
the sport's lone black driver.
-NASCAR announcing,
"The flag runs contrary
to our commitment
to providing a welcoming
and inclusive environment
for all fans"
and is now "prohibited from
all NASCAR events
and properties,"
effective immediately.
-Oh, my God.
This can only mean one thing --
NASCAR is Antifa.
Next thing you know,
they're gonna start wearing
helmets to hide their faces
and attacking people with
glass bottles.
[ Gasps ]
And I don't know much
about NASCAR,
other than the fact that 38%
of the drivers
seem to be named Rusty,
but that's an
impressive step to take.
I applaud you.
And if some of your fans boo,
maybe you can just
drown them out by --
I don't know --
driving 50 cars 200 miles
per hour around a track.
That might work.
Anyway, I honestly
can't even believe
it's a question
at this point whether or not
we should be
celebrating the symbols of
an explicitly white-supremacist
cause, like the Confederacy,
that fought to destroy
the United States.
And, yet, NASCAR
is doing more to lead right now
than the President of
the United States,
which has to be especially
bruising for Trump,
because just a few months ago,
he was the grand marshal
at the Daytona 500, even taking
a lap around the track
in his presidential limo.
So all he did was sit in the car
while it drove around
in a circle.
Trump even finds ways
to make sports lazy.
That's the least-impressive
political appearance
at a sporting event since
Chris Christie
was caught hugging
Jerry Jones at a Cowboys game.
Also, dude,
you're from New Jersey.
You have two semi-professional
football teams.
Just because they suck
doesn't mean
you get to pick another one.
The Knicks suck, but you don't
see Andrew Cuomo
hanging out with Toronto Raptor.
The Right's defense of
Confederate symbols
comes as protestors
across the country
have been taking down
Confederate statues,
like, for example, the statue of
Confederate president
and violent white-supremacist
traitor Jefferson Davis
in Richmond on Wednesday.
This morning,
Trump once again defended
Confederate symbols,
scream-tweeting, in all caps,
"Those that deny their history
are doomed to repeat it."
Of course, Trump probably most
hates the removal
of Confederate statues
because he stands like
a statue of Donald Trump that is
currently being pulled down.
I mean, seriously,
look at that forward lean.
All that's missing are
protesters pulling on cables.
"If we could just get
the chest out
a little further past the toes,
the whole thing will come down."
And, yet,
venerating the Confederacy
isn't the only insane
culture-war issue
the Right has pinned
their hopes on this week.
Now that Trump has
cratered the economy
and utterly failed to contain
a pandemic still raging
across the country,
all the right-wing weirdos
on Fox News have left is to get
mad at cartoons and Muppets.
-HBO Max's "Looney Tunes" reboot
is disarming
some classic characters.
-What?!
-Elmer Fudd's rifle is gone.
No more.
-Oh, no.
-Yosemite Sam's 6-irons -- out.
-Six-shots.
-He's been disarmed.
-Foot washing, and now Fudd
without the rifle.
Okay, there...
-Well, it's virtue signaling.
-Yeah, I'm bringing this sign
to the protest
at the community center later.
-Oh. Well, they look upset.
Are the protesters sad?
-They are sad and upset.
And they have
every right to be, Elmo.
People are upset because racism
is a huge problem
in our country.
Across the country,
people of color,
especially in
the black community,
are being treated unfairly
because of how they look.
-It's a children's show.
Got that, Bobby?
America is a very bad place,
and it's your fault.
So no matter what happens,
no matter what they do to you
when you grow up,
you have no right to complain.
That's the message,
and it starts very young.
-Think of how far
you've fallen in life
when you're mad at a Muppet.
I mean, just steaming all day,
barking at your producers,
"Get me that footage
of Elmo's dad.
And look into Beaker, too.
He's awfully quiet."
It's especially surprising
that Tucker is mad
at a children's show,
because for most of his career,
he dressed like a child.
You know, he always looked
like the ring bearer
at a Connecticut wedding.
"Okay, Tucker,
give them the rings.
Tucker, Tucker,
come on, the rings.
Oh, my God!
Tucker, did you eat the rings?!
Oh, Tucker!
Tucker! Tucker!
We expected more from you."
The Conservative grift has been
so thoroughly discredited
by the failures of
the Trump presidency
that Fox has been
reduced to yelling about
children's cartoons and Muppets.
And Trump, meanwhile,
has pinned his hopes
for a political resurgence
on defending
racist Confederate symbols.
And when they decided on
that strategy
at the Trump
campaign headquarters,
I'm sure Trump went out of his
way to brag that he --
-Spent some time
working on that.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
-Happy birthday.
[ Laughs ]
♪♪
-As New York struggles
to reopen this week,
remember that we are still
a city in crisis.
And City Harvest
has been stepping up
to meet the increased need.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the "donate" button.
Stay safe. Wash your hands.
We love you.